Oh
est-il possible de manquer un endroit où vous n'êtes
jamais allé plus à une époque où vous n'avez
jamais vécu avez-vous des souvenirs
avant celui de la sécurité notre travail est de ne pas
se souvenir du premier jour 64 ou de la nuit
califor c'est Mission Control
comment y  'tous en train de faire ce beau matin
c'est Jack Harper je suis prêt à partir
êtes-vous une équipe efficace nous sommes une
équipe efficace
il y a soixante ans la terre a été attaquée
nous avons gagné la guerre mais la planète perdue l'humanité
a dû quitter la terre nous avons dû désapprendre
quoi  cela signifiait appeler quelque chose notre maison les
restes de l'armée de charognards
restent encore à la surface
mon travail est la sécurité et la maintenance des drones
avec un groupe de nettoyage 166 gardez votre char
hors du véhicule ouais humain je vous ordonne
de retourner à la tour
tirer immédiatement  sur Survivor voir c'est un
comportement insubordonné
dis moi est-ce qu'il ramène de vieux souvenirs
où est-elle je t'ai regardé jack
ils t'ont menti il ​​est temps d'apprendre le
sélecteur de vérité nous devons partir maintenant
capitaine êtes-vous toujours une équipe efficace
êtes-vous
ce k  ind de
survécu c'est le seul moyen